the united states european union and
other western nations have pledged to
support efforts to secure justice and
accountability for myanmar's rohingya
muslims five years back on this day
myanmar's military began a brutal
crackdown against the rohingya forcing
some 740 000 of them to flee to
neighboring bangladesh the u.n later
said myanmar's actions were driven by
genocidal intent the united states
earlier this year called it a flat out
genocide most of the rohingya ended up
as refugees near the town of cox's bazar
in bangladesh it now holds a million
refugees and bangladesh is hoping they
will all eventually return to their home
country
but the rohingya remain in limbo caught
between an impossible dream to return to
myanmar and their reality as refugees in
bangladesh dw's zober ahmed reports
[Applause]
rohingya children learning myanmar's
national anthem
even though their home country does not
want them in the school in a bangladeshi
camp the refugees are trying to hold on
to their culture and identity
[Applause]
the children also learned subjects such
as english math and life skills
many fled here after the myanmar
military started a brutal campaign
against the rohingya in 2017.
mishara crossed the border with her
family five years ago
i like life skills the most i wake up in
the morning and go to school
after school i go home and in the
afternoon i go play
when i grow up i want to teach
mishara lives with her parents and five
siblings in a hut in the hills inside
balukali camp
her mother tasmida begum is concerned
about her kids future
she recalls what she had to leave behind
when she fled
now that they are growing up i'm
stressed when i think about their future
when i think about my homeland i get
emotional we were well off we did not
have our own land but we had a cow three
goats and a house
her husband mama cheffy used to work in
the farmlands back in myanmar but here
he hardly has any work the couple each
lost family members when the military
went on a rampage
[Music]
then they opened fire and people were
killed
when we left they burned our houses to
the ground we thought there's no point
staying here we should flee to
bangladesh
then we left and they burned our houses
while we were fleeing toward the border
they killed my brother-in-law
there are countless stories like these
among camp residents people here are
living in limbo a limbo that seems to
never end
five years after
what has been called the biggest mass
exodus of rohingya to bangladesh
they want to rebuild their lives
[Music]
but they have limited education and they
can't go out of these camps
many of them tried to flee to other
neighboring countries but it seems
nobody really wants them
bangladesh does provide support to the
refugees but they also stress that the
rohingya must never forget they will
have to leave one day
we are giving them humanitarian aid our
goal is that they will return to their
homeland
for example in the learning centers they
sing their national anthem they are
being told that this is not your country
you should go back
and tasmida say they know this very well
they long for their motherland but
getting back there will require much
more than teaching them a patriotic song
joey is the executive director of the
burma human rights network he joins me
now from london mr gerwin five years on
from their exodus from myanmar are the
rohingya the world's forgotten refugees
thanks for having me today uh yes
exactly this is what happening to today
what you see
uh after five years these people the
plight of the rohingya is almost
forgotten because of the different
crisis in the world today but it doesn't
mean
the rohingya situation genocide problem
is solved these peoples are genocide
survivors they are traumatized they need
help
and i see that the bangladesh government
has helped them and you know that's
really grateful but not allowing them
the education is killing their souls so
international community need to
highlight on on that matter
rohingya children are now growing
without education which is very very
dangerous i'd just like to talk about
the point of genocide that you did raise
i mean that is a word that has been used
by the united states as well what are
the chances you think anyone will be
held to account
i mean this is the political will of
international community look
international justice system is not the
legal system at in our in in countries
it is most about the
politics involved here so the political
will of international community is very
key here
to key key matter here and key factor
here so we need to international
community need to understand that
failure failure to
send this
genocidal generals to icc is allowing
them to commit further crimes as you see
that if we
take action effectively in 2012
we won't see genocide in 2017
but we failed to take any action even in
genocide genocide uh
event in 2017
that also allowed this general to kill
everyone in the country today like crime
against humanity they are committing now
so each event we failed to to to take
action it's also giving opportunity to
that criminal to take uh to commit
another crimes to with more people and
then their the the the
crimes that they are committing you see
that not only one location is a
nationwide
right so that's what impact all the
regional uh stability and safe safety
and security and instability as well
now the the myanmar government has
agreements with
both bangladesh and the united nations
to accept the return
of the rohingya but this hasn't yet
happened do you think it will ever
happen
because that is what uh we human rights
organization always crying about the
international community to help try to
tell the
any agreement the military is com they
never commit any any any agreement look
how many
agreements they have with bangladesh
government to repatriate the rohingya
people who those who
you know fled in
previous years and decades
until now it never happened so
democratic the diplomatic approach with
the military regime is always faith
we cannot we cannot negotiate with them
these are the criminal thugs they need
to be punished they need to be brought
to justice they are not supposed to
shake hand
with the u.n leaders and any
international leaders that is very
damaging that we condemn that
you know you're painting a pretty grim
picture i therefore have to ask you is
there at all uh a possibility of a
secure future for the rohingya in
myanmar
uh as long as uh one thing we need to
understand that rohingya peoples they
are people who has determination courage
you know they have faith
they have uh they have a unity
we need to build up these people these
people has been suffered several decades
right even at least six seven decades
under the military regime you know
oppressed by the military regime the
everything has been taken away from them
so we need to build up this community
international community need to do their
best to try their best to build up their
community to stand up on their own they
will find their way to return to home
they have a capability for that all
right
we'll have to leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us today joey executive director
of the burma human rights network thank
you sir
thank you very much
neighboring india hasn't been as
supportive as bangladesh towards
rohingya refugees some 40 000 of them
live in india but officially india does
not recognize them as refugees even if
the u.n does that's because india is
neither a signatory to the 1951 refugee
convention nor does it have a national
refugee policy
the result constant harassment for the
rohingya
a makeshift shelter in southern delhi
this is how most exiled rohingya live
across india
in tents or camps with no access to
basic amenities
they're called the most persecuted
minority in the world by the u.n
the indian government though has a
different name for this community
illegal foreigners
sanjita begum was forced to flee from
myanmar years ago
she makes it clear that she and her
community are refugees
[Music]
i'm 29
and i've spent 22 of those years as a
refugee
i have two kids who often ask me where
their home is
where their country is
i cannot answer them
she says it pains her when her community
is called illegal migrants and at times
even criminals
and a threat to national security
these terms were back in the spotlight
recently
the housing minister announced india
would be moving the rohingya to proper
flats
the home ministry quickly denied that
was the case
most of the people living here have
refugee cards given to them by the unhcr
the united nations high commissioner for
refugees but those cards have barely
helped them it also does not help that
india does not have a national law or a
policy to deal with refugees it is also
not a signatory to international laws
that outline refugee rights
lawyer colin gonzalez who has
represented rohingya muslims in the past
says it is not entirely correct that the
country does not have a legal framework
for refugees
we have a perfectly legal framework in
terms of the orders of the supreme court
of india under our constitution a
judgment of the supreme court
operates like a statute
that has the same status as a law made
by parliament we have lovely judgments
of our supreme so we have a perfect
system
india doesn't want to formalize that
system
that is what upsets muhammad haroon
he has been living in this camp for 12
years
he's close to tears when he shows us his
refugee card
[Music]
stay here in the way we have been living
for so long
if the government here and the united
nations can help us to get our rights
back in myanmar
we will be ready to go back
like haroon many other rohingya here
have nearly given up hope several times
their main wish remains that at least
their children
get a chance at a better life
so
bangladesh stresses that the rohingya
will eventually have to go home but
their home country myanmar doesn't want
them how long is bangladesh prepare to
support them
well bangladesh has been supporting or
giving up this kind of
humanitarian aid to these people for a
long time like the latest
mass exodus
occurred in 2017 since then like
more than uh one million people are
already living here in these camps you
can see right behind me so uh
the thing is but i talked to the people
talk to the officials bangladesh
officials they say that
they uh are providing this support they
will do it but they eventually they want
them to go back and they want to uh
expedite the process the repatriation
process and for that already there is a
task force that is working on uh the
list a list of the rohingya migrants uh
the list they have provided it's a list
of around
830 000 rohingya people they have
already submitted it to the myanmar
government so they hope that this
republican process will uh will will go
forward uh whereas
uh before
twice this repatriation atom uh have
been failed so they want the foreign
minister already said that that they
want it to be expedited
now today they were under i understand
protests by some of the rohingya
refugees there
and you were there what are they calling
for
well uh there are 34 camps inside this
uh big uh uh
big uh
[Applause]
you can see that just behind me like uh
there are 34 separate camps and in every
camp there was a protest there was a
gathering of these people they say that
they want justice they want
the myanmar authorities to be held
responsible for what they have done
at least five years ago and
they say that they want their
citizenship and ethnicity recognition of
their ethnicity back in myanmar they
want to go back
but they want a security insurance they
want safely
go back to their country
dws zubair ahmed reporting there from
bangladesh thank you very much
tom andrews is the un's special
rapporteur for human rights in myanmar
joins us now from hartford in the us uh
welcome tom you have criticized the u.n
for not doing enough to help the
rohingya in comparison to the
international response to ukrainian
refugees for example what more should
other countries be doing
there's
a tremendous amount that can be doing
first of all the level of humanitarian
aid that are being provided
by the international community uh is is
well below what is the fundamental
requirements of of the of these people
so from a from a humanitarian point of
view this is extremely important but the
key here i think
is accountability there have been
there's five years after these horrific
attacks
no one has been held accountable for
these acts and as a result of that i
believe
the the military junta has been
emboldened uh to commit even more crimes
war crimes crimes against humanity so in
my view it is critically important for
the international community to engage in
coordinated focused targeted sanctions
cut off the revenue flow to the hunter
cut off the weapons to the hunter and
engage in accountability mechanisms in a
much more robust way than what the
international community has been willing
to do starting with the security council
the international criminal court the
international court of justice the the
case that the gambia has brought forward
uh to make it clear to the world this is
a genocide um some nations have joined
most nations have not
it is important that there be an
organized focused coordinated effort the
likes of which we have yet to see
now you've also said that atrocities are
still being committed with impunity by
the regime in myanmar do you have any
examples you've come across
yes just today i've been speaking to
people inside
of rakhine state they're telling me that
the attacks against uh rohingya people
have been have increased there are six
hundred thousand more than six hundred
thousand rainbow living uh in great
danger in rakhine state right now one
hundred and thirty thousand of them are
living in what can happily be described
as open-air prisons concentration camps
conditions are just absolutely horrific
a man told me that if the world cannot
help uh them and their in their plight
inside of of myanmar then please just
bomb these camps it would be better for
our family to die underneath the bomb
than to continue to live in these
conditions uh systematic torture uh
murder uh we're we're recording uh
sexual violence against people inside of
uh myanmar
right now including members of the ranga
community and other communities
so this is continuing with impunity and
i'm afraid to say based upon what i'm
learning even just within an hour ago
um that the intensity of this
these attacks uh and this impunity uh is
increasing as we literally as we speak
uh tom andrews the un's special
rapporteur on human rights in myanmar
thank you very much for your time
thank you
you